knock knock who's there explosion knock
knock who's there hammer time knock
knock who's there bullets in Rainbow six
siege you really don't want to answer
the door which is actually pretty easy
because there really aren't any doors
there are doorways and window frames but
they tend to be barricaded or reinforced
and they tend to get blown up or shot
through with alarming frequency doors
and windows are dangerous then again so
are walls floors and ceilings if it's
not the roof of a house or the exterior
of a plane odds are someone can kill you
through it and speaking of plane there's
a new map in the closed alpha version of
Rainbow six siege that we played this
isn't your average commuter plane though
it's one of those three-story
presidential deals with meeting rooms
and cargo holds and sneaky ladders for
hopping down behind dudes and popping
them real good there are fewer points of
entry than on the house map which was
shown at e3 last year and the windows
are bulletproof so defenders can engage
early if they spot where the attackers
are coming from and maybe lay a little
c4 surprise this kind of bottle nucking
can burn time off the clock and the 3
minute countdown is one of the big
motivators in siege time can move
surprisingly quickly between planning
and filtration getting messed up having
to make an entire new plan etc etc
there's also the kill countdown which
updates anytime someone is killed
letting you know which way the momentum
is swinging add to that the mounting
tension of hearing breach explosions
getting closer and closer and closer to
you and then suddenly the ceiling is
exploding all around you and oh my god
they're coming in from above but no
that's just a distraction tactic and now
they're in the room with you ah nuts
conventional wisdom holds that knowing
is half the battle but in Rainbow six
siege it feels like three quarters would
be more accurate scouting the enemy's
position is crucial to formulating and
adapting your battle plan and knowing
the map layout makes the difference
between being the flanker or the flank
II but just as important as knowing
where your enemy is is knowing it ooh
your enemy is 20 unique operators will
populate Rainbow six siege and in the
closed alpha we got to play as 10 of
them though at first glance they look
like a bunch of jackbooted stormtroopers
they each have distinguishing attributes
that will allow sharp-eyed players to
gain valuable intel on what's coming
their way spot a guy with a classic
looking gas mask during the drone
scouting phase watch out for toxic gas
traps stuck to the walls is there a big
fella with a riot helmet your enemies
might have extra armor to absorb your
bullets and what about that hulking goon
with the big ol sledgehammer well you
can guess how that's going to go oh yeah
now that you know what's coming you can
take steps to neutralize your opponent's
strengths EMP grenades can keep those
gas traps from being remotely triggered
a heartbeat sensor can help you shoot
accurately through floors and ceilings
to shred that armor and reinforced
barricades will slow down even the
hammer in his tank in town tactics and
counter tactics actions and reactions
the core of Rainbow six siege lies in
this ever-evolving strategic battle
flanking outside the house to surprise
the attackers might work one round but
next time around they'll be ready an
electronic jammer might stymie your
buddies breach charge forcing you to
fire around from your breach charge
launcher players choose their operators
each round selecting which unique
abilities to bring into battle and which
to leave behind and adapting that
strategy from round to round these
choices throw a whole new crop of
considerations into the all-important
battle for Intel which leads us to the
question of how your team will share all
this Intel voice chat is pretty clearly
the best way and a communicative team is
much more fun to be on and generally
more successful but a game developer
can't rely on their players to feel
chatty as of now Ubisoft is still
working on the in-game communication
systems so all we can do is speculate
will there be silent emotes that require
line of sight between teammates or vocal
call-outs that the enemy might overhear
a spotting mechanic like the one used in
battlefield or something like the
countdown timer from Portal tues
cooperative mode at the end of our time
with rainbow 6 siege we couldn't stop
thinking of different strategies to
I and ways we could have countered our
opponents rappelling into Windows is an
action hero move but it was the guy who
repelled just above our window that got
the better of us that time a trapdoor
exploded right above us but we tossed c4
up into the hole and got a kill
delightful Rainbow six siege is
currently slated to come out this fall
on pc xbox one and ps4 but there's a
closed alpha coming up soon that you can
sign up for online if like us you just
don't want to wait that long to try out
some strategies of your own stories of
triumphant failure and siege aren't just
fun to share there are also valuable
learning lessons because it seems like
there's always something else to try or
something you've never even thought of
you